this is Toby capwell historian author
and expert on medieval and Renaissance
arms and armor today he's joining us to
share his reactions to the Warriors of
Warhammer fantasy and 40K using some of
warhammer's games images and animations
people often think of knights being the
antithesis and the opposite to gunpowder
weapons and the people who use them
they're saying here what if Knights
existed in a technological future yeah
they'd love automatic weapons be sure to
check out our previous episode with Toby
as well as our other experts such as
xsas Billy Billingham and let us know in
the comments what games universes arms
and armor you'd like to see on the show
right over to Toby
protect of their land s on flying horses
that's a new one it's hard enough to
command regular heavy Cavalry uh I mean
a guy in armor has no idea what's going
on he can't see very much he can't hear
anything can't even imagine what kind of
a mess it would be to have Knights
flying around on winged horses
and here they're actually varying it a
bit more so the individual Knights have
got their own colors their own heraldic
devices the equipment is is different
some of them got their helmets on some
don't that's looking that's looking good
actually use the two-handed weapons on
Horseback it's usually not a thing you
need your left hand to control the horse
they're mixing references from different
historical periods but maybe in the in
the context of this fantasy environment
they're not worried about that this is
looking like the 13th 14th century this
infantry more or less by that point we
do know that there was use of
identifying colors and like Livery
badges identifying foot soldiers as
belonging to a certain night or whatever
I'm not sure what that's supposed to be
it's like a corpse some kind of weird
mascot
why are they on the ground shouldn't
they be like dropping bombs or something
isn't that what air power is for
[Laughter]
I'm obviously it's another very you know
deeply Fantastical situation but they
they captured something of what kind of
individual nightly visual impact is like
but in the overall kind of visual
character
you know I think that was you know that
was interesting to look at
[Applause]
so these guys immediately have kind of a
slightly more Renaissance flavor to them
like all the Scrolls and inscriptions on
the the Griffin's armor there that has a
very kind of German Renaissance early
16th century kind of feel about it and
again it's
nice to get those references even in a
in a in a fantasy game and there you go
there's some more Renaissance troops
right there lightly armored handgunners
yeah I mean they were in the early 16th
century when they're you know where
they're drawing their inspiration from
this there was a kind of mini heavy
Cavalry Revolution where you know there
was a renewed interest and use of of
heavily armored you know Cavalry and so
you know that kind of works with this in
a in a weird way oh this is cool these
are like light Cavalry they're wearing
armor again very Renaissance this is
like second quarter of the 16th century
they've got handheld Firearms they're
more lightly armored their horses have
no armor so they can move faster that's
that's all totally real and legitimate
that's that's nice looking Lance
connects all that very flamboyant puffed
and slashed clothing now here divesting
yourself of helmets and the guy's just
wearing big hats that's a real thing the
lungs connects were famous for for that
although plenty of them did wear helmets
too the Lance connects were like German
and swiss mercenary companies in the
early 16th century I mean for for
Fantasy this has a very strong very
specific historical through line which
is really really nice to see alongside
the Griffins and whatever I guess those
are female Griffins then Griffins
without wings well in the older you know
medieval mythology female Griffins don't
have wings it's a bizarre mashup Now
isn't it with these uh hulk-like Orcs
and goblins and stuff I mean it because
they obviously don't have any sort of
strong historical basis to them they're
not making those sorts of references so
it from a design point of view it
actually really accentuates the the
serious contrast between one type of
force and another I like that a lot
actually I like that more than I thought
I did
actually or I thought I would again it's
fantasy but with a lot of complex
reference to human reality that's what
makes it good
I actually really like it when you see
these guys with their helmets off
because there's this really interesting
dichotomy in the character between you
know the identifiable human and what the
armor transforms them into
not support this action
you know because the armored body is
becoming something more than human
that's what like medieval nightly
culture is totally based on
you know Knights historically were the
aristocracy and the aristocracy claim
the rights to rule on Earth directly
from God God had chosen them as a
special people to wield special Divine
powers that weren't available to the
rest of humanity these are not ordinary
human beings they're special they're
powerful they are superhuman in a very
literal material tangible way
and I and I think the design of the
Space Marines and Warhammer is really
keying into that as well they're showing
you the human inside versus their
armored identity
and that really comes across when you
see them without their helmets and the
contrast between the the effect of a
Space Marine when he's got the helmet on
versus when you can see his face it
becomes an identifiable human again it's
uh it works really well
saved yourselves another relationship
with the common soldiers is really is a
nice contrast as well I mean generally
throughout Warhammer and throughout all
the space marine armor they always tend
to have these solid one-piece shoulder
plates
where the entire shoulder almost to the
to the Elbow
is covered by one single big plate again
if you look at real real armor
mobility in here
is really critical if you don't have
that that those plates that can collapse
and move with this action you can't move
now maybe with their heavy weapons the
Space Marines they don't need to move
their arms upwards very much but
even in those suits I think that would
have been a problem that where they're
relying on the digital artists to
magically give them more Mobility than
they probably would actually have but
you know again this is starting to get
beyond the realm of a of a medieval
art historian to comment I guess he
seems to be coping why are we not
captain
I've saved some Orcs for you and you
know the use of weapons like that is
very consistent too you know people
often think of of historically of
knights being the antithesis and the
diametric opposite to gunpowder weapons
and the people who use them but actually
a lot of and of the earliest handheld
gunpowder weapon technology was
developed first for Knights to use on
Horseback in armor a contrary to a lot
of popular misconception the knights or
the first people to to use the that new
technology so you know they're saying
here what if Knights existed in a
technological future yeah they'd love
automatic weapons
okay a chainsaw Sword whatever works I
guess
well I mean if you're if you're fighting
Orcs like this who may have really thick
skin and really dense muscle you might
you might need something special to get
through that and there there's an
interesting hypothesis that uh
Gladiators in ancient Rome often allowed
themselves to gain weight and even
became kind of overweight
so that the actual the the fat and the
the skin and everything would allow them
to be cut and lacerated in Theatrical
gladiatorial combat without suffering a
serious internal injury so you know the
actual makeup of the body the thickness
of the skin the amount of fat and muscle
on there is a is another consideration
here perhaps and I mean Romans never had
chainsaw swords but I bet they would
have liked them
and now the knights are coming to save
their poor common Soldiers by showing it
from the common soldiers perspective
gives it a really amazing kind of
emotional impact you know it shows
they've thought about that and there's a
great contrast between his gear and his
physical size and what the common
Soldier has to work with sometimes you
know when I talk about armor as a kind
of a visual expressive art form people
seem a bit quizzical because we're so
used to thinking of armor in Practical
terms as equipment for fighting modern
mind often has a problem with the idea
that something can be a utilitarian
object and an expressive work of art at
the same time
but the you know the proof is found in
the effectiveness of images like this
where these guys have loads of stuff on
their gear that's got nothing to do with
function
it doesn't you know put in the big
winged skulls on their breastplates and
everything and the gold decoration
that doesn't make them any safer it but
it's all about the visual impact of of
that and here we're seeing them arrive
on the battlefield and the incredible
kind of morale boost that would be to
Common soldiers
and a lot of that comes through on it on
that expressive artistic level so from
that point of view Warhammer and Space
Marines are a very historically
authentic
[Laughter]
there's no denying it it's pretty cool
but I'd never want to go there
I gotta pull the rat the rat man up on
one thing here if you stop for a second
it may look cool and everything but you
don't need a giant pendant loin cloth of
mail hanging all the way down
practically to the floor there's nothing
there to protect yes okay put some mail
over your genitalia that's not a bad
idea but it doesn't need to be hanging
down that far that's wasteful and and
and weight inefficient so rat people
get with it
kind of interesting that they're
wrestling with the problem of making a
helmet for uh
a rat person what does a helmet for
something like that look like it's kind
of a fun a fun problem
it's getting very surreal very fast
how's he getting so many shots out of
single shot weapons oh he's got lots of
pistols fair enough you've got to be
really careful about in Practical terms
in real world terms is covering your
body in spikes when you have spikes on
your body you are just as dangerous if
not more dangerous to yourself and
anybody immediately around you who has
to work with that armor who has to take
it off or put it on or whatever I mean
in a Fantasy Realm there might be a
reason for doing it like the legend of
the Lambton worm it's a myth it's a real
medieval myth it's a John Lampton it's
the local night it's his responsibility
to deal with it and he has to fight this
Worm but the problem is that if you cut
it if you cut it up it just grows back
together and gets badder and scarier so
a witch tells Sir John that what he
needs to do is cover his armor with
spikes and Blades so the worm like a
python wraps itself around him and his
armor cuts it to Pieces the pieces fall
in the fast flowing river and get taken
away before they can grow back together
fine there's your rationale that's when
you need spikes on your armor there's a
good reason behind it so fine one thing
you're seeing on this guy too that's a
that's a reoccurring problem you see
that hanging down on either side of his
of his waist he's got these Spade shaped
plates
uh those are called tacits and they're
meant to protect the hips and the
juncture between the top of the leg and
the pelvis really really important
plates and video games and television
designers habitually show tacits on the
sides of the leg and those tacits need
to be on the front
the front is where you get hit
right if you're a self-respecting
warrior normally Warriors like this are
concerned for their their appearance
they don't really want to be going
around covered in but you know I
can I can let that go because I I
understand that God they've got a
fantasy expressive
thing going on here plate armor can
protect you against a lot more than
people think but gunpowder weapons
are are still a always a major problem
obviously a narrow bladed little
thrusting sword like that might seem a
bit like a weedy and and wimpy for
someone like that but that's actually a
much better sword to be using for a
fully armored opponent you can stab them
in the gaps of between the armor rather
than trying to get straight through it
[Music]
oh well there's certainly a nightly
looking helmet in there somewhere this
is kind of neat because although these
are like powered exoskeletons in a
Sci-Fi Universe they're also making some
very strong medieval references here
that's fine that's fun they're using
heraldry they've got little little
shields on their left side that's the
right side to be wearing them vaguely
nightly looking helmets combined with
the technology it's not as conceptually
far-fetched as you might think either
that a nightly culture like this that
celebrates the the individual prowess of
elite Warriors that have their own kind
of exclusive culture that's ruled by a
set of ideals or or moral precepts it
very much goes hand in hand with the
technology in the Middle Ages the
technology was the horse and the ability
to fight on a horse at a high level and
to have all this fantastic armor and as
we moved into the modern world we've
we've got we've lost a lot of that cult
of personality and in individual hero
prowess in modern militaries that's not
what modern militaries are about
except in a vague whisper in like
fighter pilots or something where
there's almost a little bit of that
Dynamic still going on there is the hint
that in the Next Generation or two we
will start seeing hydraulically powered
combat suits that then can reinvigorate
potentially a nightly culture where you
have these you know technologically
empowered specialist Elite Warriors once
you've got the technology taking you
there the culture nap the human culture
naturally kind of gets embroidered
around it so this this actually kind of
strikes me as as weirdly plausible in a
less literal way though I really like
how the the Warhammer designers have
really got their head around
the incredible expressive power and
potential that armor has you know these
guys are perfectly aware
that an armor is more than just fighting
equipment that it's turning the wearer
into this extraordinary work of visual
art
and it's broadcasting it's radiating all
kinds of complex messages about the
person inside their loyalties their
beliefs their you know everything about
them is being constantly broadcast by
their equipment and you'd be you know a
lot of people don't understand that and
it's nice to see that that some people
in the industry really do get that
lots of skulls and spikes yeah this is
uh
it's kind of hard kind of hard to miss I
guess most of his cool trophies would
just get immediately wrecked in this
kind of combat I actually like the use
of color here too I mean they do still
look like individuals even though
they're all the same color and
historically armor was painted they're
not all nights were
shining and mirror polished a lot of
lower status armor was Paul was just
painted paint is a cheap way of making
lower quality armor look nicer than it
actually is
so you know having having red armor like
this isn't necessarily in itself as
Fantastical as it might seem is there a
monster face helmets with the big horns
do start to feel a bit a little bit
goofy though whatever you're wearing you
know you do have to be able to take
yourself seriously on the battlefield
come on
now here's an interesting use of spikes
I've been going on about how I don't
like spikes a lot but here the the use
of spikes is is actually a historical
reference the the single Spike coming
out the top of the helmet is a reference
to the German Imperial
uh military helmets of the late 19th and
early 20th centuries so-called picklehub
so that's like a cultural reference
point so you put a spike on a helmet
like that no matter what else you do
you're thinking these guys are Teutonic
Imperial you know probably not very nice
characters you know they look kind of
like they're suffering from some kind of
armor plague seems like they're
celebrating kind of degradation and
Decay you're exactly right oh really and
they're actually the trench fires of
that faction oh really
great well there you go there's good
design then if that's what it says then
that's what it is 10 out of 10.
fanatical zealots
[Music]
nice detail of the Rosary hanging down I
think a rosary on the Belt kind of some
kind of
religious reference there that's kind of
neat the helmets clearly derived you
know sci-fi abstraction of a 15th
century salad again with a a tail and a
visor the fleur-de-lis that they're
using here is a very generic very
typical heraldic device it's most
commonly associated with France because
the the coat of arms of the medieval
kings of France was a blue shield with
gold fleur-de-lis or heraldic lilies
basically on it the fleur de lis by no
means exclusively French it appears on
heraldry all over the place the the
sisters or whoever they are perfectly
entitled to use it if they want
something about the geometry and the
form of it it's just really classically
medieval it's one of these images that
is almost now for present purposes
almost too generically medieval I mean
so much of what Warhammer is doing is
it's very skillful integration of sci-fi
and historical references I think it
works fine here women wearing armor
fighting an armor historically was
pretty unusual it did happen and and
certainly the the image of a woman in
armor does appear again and again
historically in art that's kind of a
quite a powerful archetype and it
certainly puts a different spin on their
existing kind of aesthetic there's never
any such thing as obviously female armor
breastplates with allowance volumetric
allowance for the breasts is a fantasy
there's really no precedent for that
historically at all someone like Joan of
Arc in the 15th century in France was a
woman who really did wear plate armor
leading French Army against the English
and the later part of the Hundred Years
War the the purchase documents for her
armor that was made for her on the
orders of the king of France exist we
know she had it
but as far as we can tell the armor that
a woman would wear was just a armor of
the appropriate size once it was all put
together you wouldn't be able to tell
that it was a woman I have several you
know women friends in the jousting
Community who are great jousters
when they're all put together in their
armor on their horse their visors down
there's nothing that would tell you that
they're women
and it's just purely the sport against
other people who have the guts to go
against you in the field and the the
gender issues just kind of disappear
here they here they obviously don't
disappear and they don't want them to
but this is a place where Warhammer is
really going
almost Pure Fantasy
[Applause]
I'm not sure the armor that they're
wearing is good enough protection for
the danger of this environment I think
everybody would be horribly injured very
quickly here I guess that's the point
the pot the cooking pot on the head is a
nice little touch that's that's
something you actually see in real late
medieval Renaissance art when they're
sort of Hieronymus Bosch and uh bruchel
and other netherlandish painters when
they want to come up with a ridiculous
fantasy satire of the armored body the
cooking pot on the head is a thing no
Spike cheerleaders now
again I'm sort of worried for her safety
it's sort of hard to criticize this
because like the real armor that
American footballers wear is is totally
insufficient a little bit of armor can
often be more dangerous
than wearing no armor at all because it
can give you a false sense of safety
sometimes it's actually better not to
wear any armor at all but their armor
for what they're doing seems inefficient
insufficient thank you so much for
watching Remember to comment below what
other games you'd like to see on the
show and be sure to subscribe for more
content like this and Beyond